Jennifer: Hi. My name is Jennifer, and this is SGT. Tracking your expenses with money manager one
Jennifer: UOCI dash RCLL. Dash 8,
Jennifer: and again, my name is Jennifer, and I am using a pixel sixa. I have the latest version of Android, which is
Jennifer:  OS 14. And I am using
Jennifer: talk back as my screen reader.
Jennifer: And today I am working with the money manager. App.
Jennifer: Okay.
Jennifer: okay.
Jennifer: So now, I wanna go in this app. And I wanna
Jennifer: create expense categories and add an income. Okay? So I'm gonna I'm at the top left of the app here. Expenses. Oh, maybe not.
Jennifer: Category. Name more options, expenses, open navigation. Oh, here we go. Okay, there's more options. Category name
Jennifer: as category. Name, too. Expenses this month.
Jennifer: So let me go here to Category name, and I'm gonna double tap on it.
Jennifer: More options. Category name. Okay, no expenses this month.
Jennifer: Let me go into more options.
Jennifer: Oh, here's add income. Well, I need to do that. So let me double tap on, add income.
Jennifer: and then I swipe to the right, and it says, money amount. I'm gonna double tap on it. And I'm gonna say.
Jennifer: apologies for the pause. I had to turn my audio fix my audio situation because my audio was too quiet. Okay? So now I'm in the income and I'm gonna put down the amount.
Jennifer: So by 2,
Jennifer: one
Jennifer: 9 0 0 0 0 0. Okay, there's my income. So I'm gonna go.
Jennifer: I think I press, maybe enter.
Jennifer: Oh, done. Okay, there's a done button here. So I pressed the done button.
Jennifer: and
Jennifer: after your wallet
Jennifer: addicup button, double tap on the add income button.
Jennifer: There we go. That works okay, and it says that it contains $1,000. Come on expenses, more options.
Category name.
Jennifer: Okay? So now, I want to do the category. So when I double tapes. total expenses through expenses. This category name.
Jennifer: when I tap on category name nothing happens this much, so I'll double tap on that total expenses.
Jennifer: Maybe I need to add expense. Let me add an expense. Okay? So I'm gonna add an expense. But double-tap and add an expense category
Jennifer: drop-down list detected. Okay? And there's a drop-down list, description, accuracy, medium. So I'll double tap on that
Jennifer: at a ritual
Jennifer: detected Icarus down
Jennifer: product category.
Jennifer: I'm double tapping on the drop-down list, and nothing is happening.
Jennifer: Characters enter 0 of 10
Jennifer: and rattle. Eddie Dodge.
Jennifer: transaction date
Jennifer: and
Jennifer: and rinse detected by dove image ants.
Jennifer: erotic catado transaction.
Jennifer: I can't get the product category button to do anything. And I double-tap on product category double-tap on that. Maybe I have to go. That's not right.
Jennifer: Okay, that doesn't do it. I tried to swipe down
Jennifer: the characters, enter 0 attack.
Jennifer: Tamarinho teletubs.
Jennifer: Transaction data 2024
Jennifer: Tuesday, February previous month. Next month.
Jennifer: February first went
Jennifer: February second, no I'm where I don't want to be. I was trying to find a place to enter the Category
Jennifer: temperamental. Maybe this is where you write the category.
Jennifer: Let me try entering it. Here, let's go.
Jennifer: Oh, this is where you put the money. Okay.
Jennifer: Webinar, 6 characters, 0 temperatures.
Jennifer: So now, when I'm trying to type, I don't get the keyboard. It just brings me to the month here
Jennifer: detected. I caught thou.
Jennifer: I don't know why I can't get this to go down
Jennifer: temperatures and box. Okay? Well, double tap on here.
Jennifer: We had. Section indeed. 2024
Jennifer: February, Monday, overview plus February. We go up to the top product category.
Jennifer: add mode transaction.
Jennifer: Okay, so I'm there.
Jennifer: Product category. When I double tip on that, nothing happens detected
Jennifer: when I try to get it to go down, nothing happens, and when I try to enter info, nothing happens.
Jennifer: Temperatures.
Jennifer: characters entered 0 or 10, maybe here, maybe if I tap on that, no
Jennifer: temper info and a dots. Oh, here's another enter info! Let me double tap on that one.
Jennifer: Characters and vowel.
Huh!
Jennifer: Transaction, and David 2024. Let me try to select a taste. Maybe I can at least do that. Next month.
Jennifer: February first, Wednesday, Wednesday, Tuesday, February. Select months a day.
Jennifer: okay, previous month.
Jennifer: Next month. February first 2020.
Jennifer: Now I'm scanning through the calendar.
Jennifer: Okay? Selected. That's good. At least that worked. Let me go. February seventeenth, February eighteenth, 2,020 detective. I calm down.
Jennifer: pepper involved. attacked.
Huh!
Jennifer: Product category.
Jennifer: tender info and docks.
Jennifer: But I can hit up
Jennifer: 2020.
Jennifer: But I can't let me try erotic category.
Jennifer: Maybe I need to start over. Let me go back. Bad button
Jennifer: money manager, add expense, button, button, annotation, but share audio annotation, add expense, button, button, badmood transaction, product, category
Jennifer: product category detected.
Jennifer: rotted cat
Jennifer: protected
Jennifer: and riddle.
Jennifer: I don't know what to do here. Can you pause? It
Jennifer: apologies for the pause. I needed to clarify the instructions with my facilitator. Okay, so I'm not able to add anything here. So I'm gonna try to go back
Jennifer: categories. But
Jennifer: more options. Category name budget.
Jennifer: clap, button, annotation button detected. Icon, add button budget.
Jennifer: category, name budget.
Jennifer: Budget. Let me double tap on budget icon, add button. Oh, add.
Jennifer: okay, I'm gonna double tap, category, name edit box. Okay? And let me type
Jennifer: stop, share. But Attica writes a maximum budget character category name budget category info
Jennifer: category name editors showing English us, OE. Delta, SSHO. E.
Jennifer: Bye.
Jennifer: by that.
Jennifer: Okay. So I double tapped on that, and I put shopping.
Jennifer: Now I need to spend in this category.
Jennifer: Add income button likes the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category.
Jennifer: Budget writes a maximum amount. Write the maximum amount of
Jennifer: okay, I'm trying to type
Jennifer: atticum with us. Wait a minute.
Jennifer: Oh, maybe I wanna go next. Okay, there we go alright. So I just went to the next button, and that got me out of it. Okay? And it got me to the category. And now there's a keyboard cool. Okay. So let me type the amount.
Jennifer: Aye, here he is. Aye.
Jennifer: I'm gonna be a good shopper this this week this month. Alright. So we got 500. And I'm gonna go to the bottom right of the screen. Deleted
Jennifer: double tap on. Done. Okay? And
Jennifer: I need to press, add income
Jennifer: money manager, open navigation door. Ok? So I press the add-in, come on, category. More options. Category name.
Jennifer: budgeted
Jennifer: shopping enlisted. Yeah, there it is. Dollars. Yup detected. Icon add annotation button window. There's the category. So now.
Jennifer: okay.
Jennifer: can you pause for a second
Jennifer: apologies for the pause. I had to clarify the instructions. They're kind of confusing. Okay. Let me go here. Open navigation drawer.
Jennifer: manual monthly manager, month's expenses, projected budget, categories, budget analysis, monthly, expensive budget lamps, annotation, annotation.
Jennifer: the money manager managing month's expenses, month's expenses. Let me tap on that, and, I think check open navigation or month's expense. More option, category. Name
Jennifer: your expenses this month category name expense, shopping, 0% coin dollar, total expense. Add expense button button expense, I think, is when I want to add no transaction. Ronnic category.
Okay.
Jennifer: temperamental.
Jennifer: the text product category that no transaction. Oh, I'm I wanted to make a new category. Let me see.
Jennifer: Product category. I have no trap.
Jennifer: I think I wanna go back
Jennifer: alright. More options. Category name.
Jennifer: budgeted
Jennifer: shopping, enlisted shopping budget. Category name, category name, budget
Jennifer: category. More options. Do I have to do more options. I can't remember how to add
Jennifer: that income.
Jennifer: Oh, I didn't want to do that. Let me go back. Button
Jennifer: money manager, more options. But category name. I wanna do that category name detected annotation button detected. Icon, add button, manager.
Jennifer: budget category, info category. Name, Benadries.
Jennifer: Okay? Oh, here we are. Here we are in the category.
Jennifer: Maybe let me double tap on it.
Jennifer: showing English, US. Qwerty, Dilda S. Sierra M.
Jennifer: OS OO. Romeo, DED. Food, and then we'll go to the next button, which is on the bottom. Right?
Jennifer: 2.
Jennifer: Dane Dane.
Jennifer: Aye.
Jennifer: that's it. 6,
Jennifer: 5, 5. Alright! There we go. Income. I think that saves money.
Jennifer: So I've done that. Now, what I want to do is I want to do a transaction budget more option, category, name
Jennifer: budget
Jennifer: shopping. Enlist 500 point own food
Jennifer: detected iconic presenter category.
Jennifer: Okay, let me go back.
Jennifer: Madden.
Jennifer: trying to figure out how to do. I think I have to go back to the months, expenses.
Jennifer: open navigation. Let me open the navigation manager, manage monthly expenses, and we'll double tap on month. 6 open navigation or months expense. More option category. Name
Jennifer: their expenses this month. Shopping, 0% cointo dollars, food
Jennifer: 0 versus coincident total expense annotation. But rental money meant. So I'm gonna double tip on that product category.
Jennifer: Okay? And so now, I need to find the category.
Jennifer: Roddick Cat at Spotted Cat detected
Jennifer: Denmark
Jennifer: characteristics, gentleman law transaction data. Maybe I have to double tap on that
trap downtown.
Jennifer: Temperamental.
Jennifer: Let me double tap on that window. Alright, here we go. Okay. So I double tapped on that down, icon. And I'm gonna do. I'm gonna press
Jennifer: double tap on food
Jennifer: and wrinkles and parts
Jennifer: carried presenters here.
Jennifer: Okay, I'm not sure if this is where I put how much money I've spent, or the name of what I bought. But let me double tap on this, add info button here.
Jennifer: E.
Jennifer: No, that ain't no.
Jennifer: he
Jennifer: meeting alright, we're gonna go back to the bottom deleted
Jennifer: next double tap on that box showing number 2. Okay. And this is the amount that I spent, and I'm gonna say, window number.
Jennifer: Aye.
Jennifer: I'll just do 59, because the 0 is being covered up by the zoom button.
Jennifer: and I better talk.
Jennifer: Character centre candidate. $55 sign.
Jennifer: clear texted. transaction date.
Jennifer: Okay, transaction date.
Jennifer: Tuesday, February 27,
Jennifer: double tap on February eleventh.
Jennifer: Okay, so now I wanna go to the
Jennifer: here and I'm gonna press
Jennifer: February Bill
Jennifer: selected temporary limits when selected, add nodes, transaction data
Jennifer: characters. All right, let me go down to the bottom and see if there's like a next button or a done button again.
Jennifer: No, I guess not.
Jennifer: dollar sign
Jennifer: clear tech surrounded action.
Jennifer: quinting Quinn.
Jennifer: son Cleveland. Next month
Jennifer: I get to the bottom of this calendar and see if I have to do anything else.
Jennifer: Let me try to scroll up containers.
Jennifer: Whoops that didn't work.
Jennifer: See? Here, let me scroll to the right
Jennifer: screen. Read, oh.
Jennifer: okay, we won't do that, either. That doesn't seem to let us scroll. Okay? And I'm gonna get out of this speechrate because I don't wanna change my speedrade
scroll. Okay.
Jennifer: maybe if I scroll, let me scroll, let me now try scroll.
Jennifer: January, December, December went overview. But out of later window navigation bar.
Jennifer: I don't see a way to save it fell apart, very present jumping up.
Jennifer: Dollar sign, clear tag, surrounded action
Jennifer: 2024.
Jennifer: I don't know if I saved it or not.
Jennifer: I'm trying to figure out what to do. Here, let me see.
Jennifer: let's see, is there a thoughts add mode's transaction?
Jennifer: Yeah.
Jennifer: Detected icon sound image animation of a green screen description, accuracy, medium. erotic category. Okay? Maybe I can go back now, I guess.
Jennifer: Alright.
Jennifer: Okay. Apologies for the pause. I was
Jennifer: struggling with what to do. So I am here on the
Jennifer: screen, and I'm gonna go try to go past the calendar. So let me do the scrolling thing.
Jennifer: Page 1487, to 2412,
Jennifer: page 14, page 1485, or 20 more quails. I think I'm going the wrong way, aren't I?
Jennifer: On February eleventh oops? Maybe not
Jennifer: 2024. Let's see here. September 20 third, 2,023 sub. September overview button out of later window navigation bar.
Jennifer: September sixteenth, 2,023. Let me keep going to the right are scrolling down. I guess. Bob's 34, 22,
Jennifer: July 2920, 23,
Jennifer: no. And I'm scrolling through the calendar. Page 14, page 1477 of 24
Jennifer: going here. I'm scrolling down with one finger, trying to get to the bottom
Jennifer: date fourteenth.
All right. I've got 2412 pages to cost
Jennifer: apologies for the pause. My! My talk, that kind of got stuck in the calendar, and I was getting really confused. So I'm still in the calendar now. And I'm gonna keep scrolling to the right.
July seventeenth, 2018
Jennifer: July, 1820, July nineteenth, July twentieth, July twentieth, July twentieth, July twentieth, July twentieth, July 20, July twentieth, July twentieth, July 2820 July 20, July 30. July 30. Bad transaction
Jennifer: alright. Finally, I found the add transaction. Button. So I'm gonna double tap on it. Category name.
Jennifer: You were expenses at shopping.
Jennifer: 0% goingo dollar includes 29 total expense. Add expense button, and I will add an expense button
Jennifer: that no transaction not in category
Jennifer: and detected icon. I press on this down, Icon
Jennifer: and I will do shopping. So I double-tapped on shopping.
Jennifer: Okay, I'm going to double tap on.
Jennifer: Okay. And I'm gonna go down to the bottom of the screen and press next, okay? And now I want to write the amount. So I'm gonna say, it's
Jennifer: 2, 5, $25. And I'm gonna go down to the bottom of the screen
Jennifer: done. Now, I'm gonna double tap on that. Okay.
Jennifer: now I have to catch a date. Oh, boy, here we go
Jennifer: a day.
Jennifer: Okay, so I did that previous month, Tuesday, February 20 seventh. No, I didn't say it was selected next month.
Jennifer: February first, twentieth 20, not a minute goes through the calendar. February when they selected today.
Jennifer: Okay, so now.
Jennifer: okay, so now I need to add one of my.
Jennifer: how much? Okay? Now, I need to edit one of your budget categories to change the name
Jennifer: or budget and save it. Okay? So I need to add one of my budget categories. Okay, so now, I need to figure that out. So let's see, I think I go into the expenses, and I think I need to go to the
Jennifer: someone, open the navigation drawer, double tap on that money manager manager. One check the budget category name budget
Jennifer: shopping and listed. Okay, I'm gonna edit the shopping.
Jennifer: Such a category involves shopping at a box category. Delete.
let's see
Jennifer: budget category info.
Jennifer: What did it just say shopping?
Jennifer: Well, maybe it will let me change it.
Jennifer: It said something to me, but I didn't hear it. Sample keyboard sample keyboard. Let me go back.
Jennifer:  Maybe I can go back. Let me go back. But window navigation bar. double, tap it back. But overview.
Let's see here.
Jennifer: budget, Category advocate.
Jennifer: shopping and thoughts. Category name press. Enter on that.
Jennifer: You cannot change the category name showing English us.
Jennifer: Okay, Delete.
Jennifer: Oh, what happened. It's let's see here.
Jennifer: I need to fit a budget category info with shopping and characters that are editing $500 budget like the maximum amount of money you can deleted.
Jennifer: Oh, oh.
Jennifer: budget space.
Jennifer: I don't even have that much money. Okay, let me go. Try to go down here.
Jennifer: Links, lines, words.
Jennifer: characters. Okay, let me go. 5 0 0,
Jennifer: Harriet.
Jennifer: 0 at the mail 0 period.
Jennifer: Deleted 0 deleted. Okay? And I will put 2.
Jennifer: There we go.
Jennifer: Budget category info shopping very presenterly. Editing 502.0 edit box. Clear text writes a maximum amount of adding up button.
Jennifer: And then, now I want to press the add income button
Jennifer: detected by annotation. But window annotation. Now let's see.
Jennifer: Now, I need to create a budget plan.
Jennifer: Ok, let's see, create a budget plan category name with more options. Open navigation
Jennifer: category name. Where do you do that? I'm gonna double tap on Category name. Maybe. I don't think so, though. Let me see.
Jennifer: Okay, Budget, let's see, I gotta go. Manager budget month expenses, budget budget analysis, monthly expenses, analysis
Jennifer: budget plans. Oh, budget plans. Here we go alright. Double tap on the budget. Plan. Open navigation door button. Okay, so let's see, I did that. I double tapped on that budget plans more options. Button. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan.
Jennifer: Your wallet contains enough money for this land. The deadlock of this lamb is vast. Let's see here. Now, it says.
Jennifer: create a budget plan and add
Jennifer: a deadline for any day next month. Okay, let's see here the deadline of his lab has passed.
Jennifer: Can I extend it? The deadline of this detected icon. Add button. Oh, here, there's an add button. Maybe this'll work. Let me double tap and add title edit box. Okay, we will call it
Jennifer: show in English, US. Cute English are Romeo, Romeo.
Jennifer: So I call that test. And I'm gonna go
Jennifer: next. Okay, plan description, and then I'm gonna press the next button deleted
Jennifer: next next edit Lamb's budget edit box showing budget? Well.
Jennifer: I have a thousand dollars, so
Jennifer: why don't I put 500
Jennifer: 0 0. 0? Okay? So I did that. I'm gonna press. The Max done. Okay. Now I have to find. And I have to do it.
Jennifer: A deadline for any day next month. Okay.
Jennifer: February 6.
Jennifer: I think it's at the top of the screen. And then the next month is there characters as the characters?
Jennifer: 500
Jennifer: dollar sign tweeted.
Jennifer: We had that night 2024 Tuesday, February.
Jennifer: There's next month, all right. We're gonna press the next month. Button. Okay, let's see here, we're gonna do march second.
Jennifer: So now I need to go to the
Jennifer: March third.
Jennifer: Can I go through this? I'm going to swipe through the calendar.
Jennifer: Add plan. Button edit successfully. Okay, so now, what I need to do is
Jennifer: check out the 2 analysis results. Okay, so, okay. So I think I wanna go
Jennifer: open navigation drawer. I think. So I'm gonna double tap on that budget analysis. And the budget analysis. I think this is what I want to do. Check open navigation. Okay? So I double tapped on that budget analysis, more options, web. 2
Jennifer: types are entitled your expenses per category this month with 2 points. Mid-value is Max. Value is 59, article
Jennifer: credit card trial version, like shopping include
Jennifer: shopping. 0 slash 0 for more information.
Jennifer: Visitor web annotation, shopping. Okay? I don't really understand what's going on here. Shopping, food, food, shopping, shopping, 0
Jennifer: 0 shop entitled More Options Web.
Jennifer: adding hub settings. No, that's not right.
Jennifer: Money manager, bipartite, more options, budget analysis, open navigation budget, annap more options. Web view
Jennifer: 5 are entitled near expenses or categories. This month with 2 boys. Mid-value is 25. Max value is 59 article.
Jennifer: Okay? Well, that's what I was able to understand. I don't really think I understand it that well, but I don't see anything else that's really resembling the chart.
Jennifer: So let me just make sure. Okay, I'm making sure. Yep, I definitely
Jennifer: concluded. This concludes the task. And
Jennifer: so I found this app really difficult to use. Part of it was that it just didn't make intuitive sense to me. I mean, it looked like there were edit boxes, but I couldn't get them to work.
Jennifer: And Then, you know, II got stuck in the calendar, and
Jennifer: couldn't get out of it, and that that was really hard, but
Jennifer:  because I think it would be easier if you could somehow collapse and expand the calendar. So maybe you know, if you want to expand it, you could double tap on a button where it would expand, cause that was probably the most difficult part for me was getting stuck in the calendar.
Jennifer: Once, I figured out, you know, like month's expenses, and you know then the budget  And all the categories under the application drawer
Jennifer: like the month's expenses and the budget category. And then, when you pressed each one it would give the title, and then I was able to kind of figure out what I needed to do in order to create the categories. And then also that
Jennifer: arrow worked to that down arrow that expanded the menus that worked as well, and I was able to choose my categories. But at first I was really really confused because I wasn't sure what to do. And then the calendar that that was really confusing for me, too, because I couldn't find where to add the expenses. I think it would be good if the add expenses was not only like maybe on the bottom, but also kind of on the top
Jennifer: so that you know you could get to it easily from wherever you were. Because otherwise, you know, it's really easy to get into the calendar, and then, if the calendar could be collapse somehow, that would be really helpful, too. But I was able to add the categories. Now, I don't really understand the analysis very well. I don't know if I'm missing something, or if I did something wrong, but I don't really understand it. All that. Well, I mean it said. I'm supposed to analyze 2 things, but I don't really know that I have
Jennifer: but I did create a budget and I was able to also do the plan. And once I kind of figured out, you know the whole thing with the calendar. It was okay, but I think it would really be good if that calendar could be collapsed.
So this concludes the task for today, and thank you so much for choosing fable.